foreign
[Music]
thank you
Christian
[Music]
s
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey fam how's everybody doing
well
welcome is this on
is this thing on
yeah test test test
is it on in the house
need the microphone for online
for online okay oh there we go there you
are hey fam
how is everybody
welcome to the table thank you so much
for being here uh but first of all happy
pride month
if you're new thank you for joining us
tonight if you're online thank you for
joining us uh we're gonna have uh a good
time but before we get started uh if
everybody we're going to try and get
into a good space to hear music to feel
moved by the spirit
um
just to kind of take a deep breath right
uh I hope everybody's week's been good
but you know sometimes weeks don't go
our way and uh this is a good space that
I hope you feel safe for you to just
kind of let down your guard take a deep
breath and be with family who loves you
so if everybody could close their eyes
just for a second
I want us to think about a few things
think of an apple tree and how it
doesn't need a sign
to tell you what it is you can tell it
by the fruit
just as we as Christians should have
fruit of the spirit we've got love joy
peace
patience
kindness
goodness
gentleness
faithfulness
and self-control
and the greatest of all of these is love
and we know that God is love
so I'm going to read from First
Corinthians 13 and I'm going to change
some words here because we know that God
is love
so take these words in breathe them deep
God is patient
God is kind
God does not envy
God does not boast God is not proud
God does not dishonor others
God is not self-seeking God is not
easily angered
God keeps no record of wrongs
God does not Delight in evil but
rejoices with the truth
God always protects
God always trusts God always hopes
and God always perseveres
if it isn't loving
it isn't God
amen
amen hey we want to invite you to take
whatever posture you know whether that's
standing or sitting or lying down
whatever you feel comfortable with
whatever is going to help you connect
with God right now as we get going on
our set so if you want to stand please
stand if you want to sit please sit I
know more of you want to stand some of
you want to stand come on let's stand
all right
three
foreign
[Music]
go on and figure out why take a trip to
your dark side go on and have a good cry
cause we're all alone
as we are we're all alone
I won't see your sadness I wanna share
your sins I wanna bleed your blood and
I wanna be ready
together
England leave what's heavy
heavy once heavy behind
what's heavy
[Music]
what's heavy behind
if your face is down take a look around
do your fingers move do your lungs
inflate are you tired are you weary of
the Hidden hay you've been holding
Heaven
are you feeling bad cause you did a bad
thing
hey
it's heavy
what's happy behind
leave what's happening
what's heavy behind
[Applause]
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful sister
[Music]
way to lose that feeling sit with the
love that's healing
fearful sister
please
what's heavy behind
believe what's heavy
[Music]
to leave what's heavy
what's heavy behind
all right kiddos you can go ahead and
head where you need to go
hope that made sense
[Music]
I love how when the kids leave it
literally is like 50 percent of our our
room just is just gone all of a sudden
people are gonna start waiting until the
kids leave to find their seats
um so what we're going to do now is
we're going to begin our prayers with
the people and for those of you who
aren't familiar with this is what we do
is we're going to read a prayer together
and then we will have a space where you
can say a name or a situation or
something that you want to say out loud
uh to to the community to God that you
want to bring to this this safe space
this presence where God resides for all
of us to pray for
so let's pray together
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
thank you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those that we have kept in
our hearts we pray to you that they may
have life and light healing and Hope
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
then my mother's womb
you formed me with your hands known in
Love by you before I took a breath when
I doubted Lord remind me I'm wonderfully
made you're an artist
[Music]
[Applause]
make all things work together
for my future
and from my
work together
For Your Glory
and for your name
there's a healing life
just beyond the clouds
[Music]
you make all things work together
for my future
for my
God
the glory
for your name
[Music]
but when I doubt it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're an artist and a
Potter I'm the canvas and the clay and I
know nothing has been wasted no failure
mistake
for my future
for my
[Music]
brother
for you
for you for your name
in my
mind I'm one
stand upon
a part no failure or a mistake you're an
artist I'm
a man
when I finish with me
with me
and I've been
living with me
finish with me
again
foreign
[Music]
through the love that you have driving
stronger
[Music]
how can I respond
foreign
[Music]
be
me I don't have much
I don't have much but I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I don't have much
much
but I have a heart that beats for you I
have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
thank you
every part of me
[Music]
wants to love you like you loved me
oh
every part of me
[Music]
wants to love you like you love
loves me
my Lord
I don't have
I don't have much but I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I don't have much
[Music]
I have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to you I have a life I'll
give to you I have a life I'll give to
you I have have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart that beats for you I
use
to have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to you I have a life I'll
give to you I have a life I'll give to
you
thank you
I don't have much
I don't have much but I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you
I don't have much
but I have a heart that before
foreign
yes Jesus
sometimes what we have just doesn't feel
like it's enough
years and years of trauma
hardship
and what we bring to you just feels like
so so little so small so broken
[Music]
the Lord the very heart that you gave us
is beating only because of you
and God that we know that even the very
little that we bring to you
you can do so much with
you can bring healing
Grace
contentment
awareness Beauty
Christ we're here for it
we want your presence
we want your love we want all of you
and we ask this in your name amen
if you want to turn to the people around
you and say hi and welcome
Brett will get us going in a minute
how many people
oh Grace and peace
my name is Brett I'm the pastor here and
it is so good to be with you all if you
need seats there's four right here
there's a few right there
and we might there's in that room there
might be extra chairs if we need to grab
some more so um you're good okay cool
well um thank you everyone thank you for
being here I turned around from worship
and said oh my goodness so many people
here for the little table
um not so little tonight and that's
that's wonderful what a gift what a gift
to um to have you all here and Among Us
and I also want to mention I know how
much courage it can take to walk through
that door and into this space and uh you
know even though for those of us who
it's not our first time we remember what
it was like that first second third
maybe even sixth you know where you're
just like okay I'm making my way in and
I don't know all these people
um and that can be really challenging
but I just want to say we are so glad
that you're here just know you are
wanted and welcome in this space
um we are for you God's heart is for you
and we just we celebrate you so thank
you for being here
um so if you you are here for the um
maybe first time second time um this is
a great night to um join us because we
are kicking off a new series and uh you
know it's always nice to like be here at
the beginning for a thing and not kind
of come in you know like this is part
eight in our 16 week series you know
you're like oh wow okay I gotta go back
and listen those messages I guess
um so here you are right at the
beginning is perfect
um and uh the title of our series is
Sticks and Stones rethinking the
church's stance on sexual orientation
and gender and um we we gave it that the
the title
um
uh well actually I'll do the subtitle
first the we included gender because I'm
wanting and intentionally not so much
this message
um but more future messages I do want to
get into the topic of like
um well a lot of times series like this
can kind of center around being like gay
or lesbian or bisexual and that's sort
of like what did the scripture say and
what's the thing I did you know and it's
sort of like anyone who's maybe intersex
or trans or something else you know
feels a little bit like okay well I
guess I'm not really mentioning that's
okay you know
um and but we will actually be getting
into there's um some passages where uh
or one passage in particular where Jesus
mentions sexual minorities
um in that time and so we'll be getting
that will come kind of later in the
series
um but uh we use the title Sticks and
Stones
um because of course the words of
scripture
um and very much this first message is
like right in line with all this um
because we get into the the so-called um
the infamous clobber passages
um as they are infamously named and um
those have been used uh in you know when
ways not to build up encourage edify you
know as first Timothy talks about how
scripture should be used but really to
to tear down to destroy to hurt and uh
and we all know that old saying you know
sticks and stones may break my bones but
words will never hurt me I mean everyone
knows well that's a lie uh it's like
words hurt a lot I mean I think of some
of our like most lasting wounds in life
you know are often not like that bully
in third grade he was so many punched me
you know it's like those kinds of things
especially if it's not chronic like we
can kind of move Beyond and sort of like
I was just an idiot you know but ooh the
words
oh
the words of people we love
you know
oh man that it it hurts it hurts so um
so that's the the title sticks and
stones and um and this is kind of our
attempt to just help us think in new
ways fresh ways about
um all of this and uh
yeah I hope it'll be a liberating uh
series for a lot of us and
um in terms of tonight the title of my
message is moving on
from the clobber passages
and
um you know I think I've thought a lot
about this is very rare for me usually
you know I'm like a weekly write a
sermon a week kind of guy because you
know these Sundays keep coming and uh
this is now version this is version five
of this message which never had like at
most I do like version three and it's
like slight modifications you know
um partly I just don't have time or just
run out of time you know um gotta roll
with whatever's there on Sunday
um but this one I just it was so near
and dear to my heart that I was like
version one not good enough version two
nope you know I just and I think kind of
what I was doing was I was trying it
wasn't just because I'd like oh I
disagree with what I wrote wasn't that
it was like I was trying to find the
heart you know of something like I'm
trying to I'm trying to get something
said that it feels like needs to be said
but it's you know you kind of write
until you figure out what you think you
know I mean just keep writing just keep
doing this is journaling there's a lot
of this what do I think
you know what I mean you have to write
until you get which is weird you'd think
well you already know what you think
you're you but it's not like that is it
like boy this heart and soul and mind
deep waters you know deep water so I
kind of was working it you know and um
and so where I came what I came to was
kind of the little I know a little
different where I ended up than I might
have thought but I'm I I hope it
resonates I hope it connects and so
here's where I want to kind of start is
there's this weird phenomena
that happens like in many different
areas of life where you have like the
difference between say like The
Specialist and the Gen the populist
and the Gap that happens between those
and I'm thinking like this could be if
you're like an expert or just really
good or knowledgeable in like a certain
area I was talking with someone today
who
um helps kids with like dyslexia and
they're like a reading specialist right
and so that's like they've done like a
deep dive into that you know but here's
the weird thing is once you do the Deep
dive
you not only learn the lingo but you're
like you're like in on the conversation
and you realize the conversation moves
you know new techniques new ways of
thinking new like that whole Community
they're talking they're processing
they're moving this can happen anywhere
you know I mean from I don't know
Neuroscience to ethics and philosophy to
of course theology I mean just all over
right there's always people having those
conversations they're moving the
conversation forward but here's the
thing
um for the rest of us we lag behind that
conversation
by sometimes decades
and this um this becomes a real problem
now it's not anyone's fault because like
well we can't all be like in the know on
everything right like we can't all be
Specialists and like up to date on every
single topic in existence right so it's
okay but um this becomes a little bit
like problematic
um especially as it relates to our topic
tonight because what I want to contend
is that
um exactly this has happened
um that what we have is this Gap where
basically
um Christian theologians and biblical
Scholars are now having one conversation
about all these topics and they have
left us 25 years behind like what I mean
is like we like the con in essence the
conversation we're having with our
friends on Facebook
is not the conversation
those folks are having like we are like
I mean if they are if they could and
they probably do China or like look and
like listen in on our convos and they're
like oh wow like oh yeah I remember when
we used to think like that back in 1993
like yeah I remember we used to have
those comments and and here's kind of
specifically the way this plays out
here's what I mean
um
very practical level I heard has some
other friends
um the table we had a booth at Pride
Dallas pride and the the festival on
Saturday and some folks from the table a
number of them were there but there was
one couple in particular
um a straight couple who are there as
allies and they had to go behind
um they noticed on the vehicles of like
just row after row after row some other
Christians had come and put out
religious literature
condemning people
and
so these wonderful people were going
behind and picking them all up and
grabbing them all and Gathering them and
throwing them in the trash now what what
was they actually showed me one of these
and I took a quick glance at it and I
was like okay yeah I know where this is
coming from and this is the gap I'm
talking about because what that
literature right because it was
presuming oh this is easy this is clear
here's a handful of scriptures and these
are super straightforward no problem no
questions at all this is an easy breezy
conversation it's just you know there's
right and there's wrong you know and uh
so here you go like this is all you need
like you know
um
and that's the Gap I'm talking about
because on Facebook it's just that easy
weirdly for Scholars
um and I'm not just talking about like
oh super Progressive affirming Scholars
no no I'm saying even among
traditionalist Scholars
they largely have moved on from what's
known as the clobber passages which is
strange because for us it's sort of like
what do you mean like even if we think
of like a series like this oh Sticks and
Stones oh I know we're going to be
talking about week after week after week
those like you know depending on how you
count them four five six seven passages
I know it can probably take one a week
and unpack them all you know
um
but actually no that's not where
scholarship is now they've largely moved
on why because they've realized that
those are incredibly problematic and not
just because like oh they can be kind of
hurtful for modern people not not just
because that like they mean as they
study then they realize like
oh what this is talking about is not
what we think it's talking about when we
read it
and of course this is done I mean
unbelievable harm and pain and so
um just for those maybe who are like
okay I think I know what you're talking
about but let me get clear and you know
I know these passages can be hard and
difficult
um but I'm just gonna read just two
um that I think one from the Old
Testament one from the new just to make
sure we know like because and again this
is where like most Christians like when
they think of conversations around you
know the question however you want to
frame the question like is being gay a
sin or
um you know does God bless same-sex
unions or something like that like this
is where Christians Minds tend to go
um but Scholars actually their minds go
different places um and so but let's
let's just touch on these so Leviticus
2013 this is like a classic one from the
Old Testament if a man has sexual
relations with a man as one does with a
woman
both of them have done what is
detestable they're gonna be put to death
their blood will be on their own heads
um you've never heard that passage you
can see why it's called a clobber
passage because I mean this is a far cry
from even like modern kind of
traditional folks who'd be with a more
traditional sexual ethic whatever who'd
be like well you know like their sexual
orientation and yes it's complicated but
you know certain people are maybe called
to a life of celibacy like you can hear
there's there's no Nuance there there's
no this is oh
all right that's Leviticus here's um
this is probably the most famous one uh
from Romans 1 26-27 because of this God
gave them over to shameful lusts even
their women exchanged natural sexual
relations for unnatural ones and the
same way men also abandoned natural
relations with women
kids ministry is excited today
with women and we're inflamed with lust
for one another
and then committed shameful acts with
their men received in themselves to do
penalty for their error
and uh
so this is you know what's so
interesting is that for us I can you
know like I see the Facebook
conversations almost every day you know
they're all like here it's just like
this is the thing this is the heart of
the conversation I mean if we're gonna
you know we're gonna have a conversation
around this and what scripture and
Christian tradition I mean it's going to
be right here this is the heart this is
everything you know
um and yet for Scholars not at all
they've like moved on
um and not just because they're so nice
or something or feel such compassionate
like no even traditional is conservative
like they're like uh yeah we don't
really use those much
um
and that's what I've been curious about
like why the Gap and
why is that and that's what I want to
unpack tonight is like huh so what do
they know that we don't know
what do they know
um kind of to that that end
there's a um a scholar named Karen Keane
she has a wonderful quote I admit it's a
little dense but don't worry we're going
to kind of unpack it because you know
she's an academic so she's writing in
you know academic ways for her peers
um she says this
traditionalists are willing to concede
on some of these points by the way in
conduct she's like talked about a lot of
points after this so now she's gonna
summarize like here's the things we can
largely agree on and she's noticed she's
using language of traditionalists she
means
um as opposed to affirming so
traditional speeds someone who holds to
a more traditional sexual ethic when it
comes to like gay marriage and things of
that nature
um so that's what she means so
traditionalists right not super
affirming Progressive people believe
this thing no no no this is um
traditionalist hey little buddy
um so Finley it's been
um so she writes this traditionalists
are willing to concede on some of these
points so here we'll get into the points
including recognizing that first
same-sex relations and Antiquity
manifested almost exclusively now
keyword There is almost she's not saying
literally exclusively there's no record
at all in Greek guardians or Plato or
anyone else of like what we would call a
quote-unquote sort of um normal you know
like gay relationship or something
um but but the vast majority are not
that
so she goes on almost exclusively as
peresti and other exploitative practices
we'll get into what all that is later
um traditionalists also admit most
people are not attracted to the same sex
because of unrestrained lust
um many celibate Christians have
testified to same-sex attraction that
has nothing to do with excess passion
some traditionalists also agree third
that objection to male male relations on
the grounds of violating uh gender Norms
is rooted in outdated views of women as
inferior however traditionalists are not
persuaded by these reasons alone at
which point she gets into some other
topics that we'll get into later in the
series but I think just I just want to
stop there
because I think even if you're like I'm
a little hazy on what all that's talking
about well she just dropped was an
absolute bombshell
because she just said all of the
conversations we're having on Facebook
are like painfully outdated and largely
I would say again largely not a hundred
percent but like largely kind of
somewhat irrelevant and missing the
point as far as the conversation that
Scholars and Specialists and folks in
that field are really having they've
moved on
um to other topics
um something called known as physical
complementarianism and like it's sort of
a creation debate anyway it's like a
totally different conversation they're
having Meanwhile we're over here like
well have you seen that Leviticus
passage you know have you seen Romans 1
oh you clearly haven't executed Romans
one if you executed Romans 1 then you
would know this is you know I mean like
like we're just stuck we're just lost
like in this Doom Loop of clobber
passages and
um and just to be clear I'm not saying
again it's bad or like it's so good to
you know do the research and like read
some books and learn
um
why we've kind of moved on
but tonight if you're like I don't know
if I'm gonna read five books on it I'm
kind of like okay well try in one sermon
to uh give you the best like little
synopsis and I feel like her quote is
the most sort of comprehensive summary
that I can imagine she just like laid it
out okay so let's like kind of unpack
this she starts with traditionalists are
willing to concede same-sex relations in
Antiquity manifested and these are the
keywords almost exclusively as peteresty
and other exploitative practices also if
you have really young children here
I don't know it it's something to be
aware of maybe if they're like super
young and it goes over their head that
could be one thing but just know we're
gonna be into some kind of adult content
stuff
um so what is you know peresti um well
that was so this was very prominent in
Greek culture like I mean Beyond levels
we can even imagine today uh basically
it's a man boy love and so if you were
like a
a Greek male you're like a mentor to
like young boy
um it was normal to have a sexual
dynamic in that relationship
like normal like this was thousands tens
of thousands of cases in like the
Antiquity like this was like in Greek
again this is sort of specific somewhat
to Greek culture Romans weren't into
this so much they were into something
we'll get into in a minute uh Master
Slave stuff all right so the Greeks this
was so in other words right when
Scholars
asked the question so what did like same
gender really what did this kind of look
like suddenly they're hit with a whole
culture where it's like
oh wow so that's what it looks like in
Greece and might it be then not even
might and so what are biblical writers
what are they starting to respond to
right you can see where it's like oh
okay this could be problematic
um
of course today you know we we hear that
like and we just we don't I don't know
we certainly don't venerate we just say
like oh that's just wrong that's like no
that's
that's not good
um but we all agree on that there's no
like big debate like I don't know what
are your views on such you know I mean
like I don't know it would be only like
the most Fringe Of The Fringe Of The
Fringe you know that's like having that
conversation
um
this is uh this is a big thing this is
what the biblical writers are starting
to respond to this is the kind of
research that Scholars are in the loop
on
um another one what is she because she
just kind of labels exploring other
exploitative practices what was that um
there's two one this is probably lesser
known we're not sure about this partly
because it's often Jewish writers
describing
um quote unquote like Pagan religions
and so we don't know if they're like
being super truthful about those or if
they're kind of being like disparaging
but what they say is there was um Temple
prostitution was hugely popular at that
time so you'd go to like make a pagan
like a or like a all for instance or
worship at a temple and while you were
there you would have like a sexual
encounter with like a male or female or
maybe both or it was like that was part
of the culture
um more likely that this is the one this
is what Romans the um Roman society was
really into this is Master Slave
exploitation today they called it like
Master Slave relations
um we would just call it rape
and uh it was basically like if you were
like the pater familias I mean like the
male head of household and you were
somewhat well to do
um you would likely have multiple slaves
because they're pretty affordable
and male female ovarian ages and you had
100 percent sexual access to them
whenever you wanted
and this is where we get into like major
differences between then and now
is there it wasn't a thing of like oh so
are you gay
you know I mean like that wasn't the cat
it was like what I don't know what you
mean all I know is I'm the head of the
household and I just do what I want
and uh
and this was again not like some friends
or like three people and all of Rome did
this like no no
this was widespread
hugely influential I mean everyone it
was just the it was just the way of the
world I don't know people didn't even
think it was weird like aside from
certain writers who are kind of like a
little bit like uncomfortable just
because of the as we'll get to in a
second unrestrained lust thing
um but this was just the way of the
world and can you see where the Gap is
starting to widen between all of the
information Scholars know about what
same sex relations kind of looked like
in Antiquity and then today when we're
trying to have a conversation around
like you know like people just entering
into like committed long-term marital
Partnerships and relationships without
any like
exploitative abuse and in other words
this is where things get quickly get
complicated with the biblical text
because you start to ask the question
what is it exactly that the biblical
writers are responding to
right and why is there such like kind of
a vehemence and a passion and an
intensity in there you know in Leviticus
in Romans 1
uh
this is where Scholars know well this is
your context
so this is the kinds of things that's
right likely in their minds again for us
though like for you know many people in
churches all over you know Texas that
met this morning whatever like this is
not this all this I just mentioned isn't
in their minds
right when they're going in like
protesting at Pride there's this isn't
does that make sense
um so okay so this is like kind of the
first um thing she names okay second she
continues traditional a traditionalists
also admit most people are not attracted
to same-sex or to the same sex because
of unrestrained lust many celibate
Christians have testified to the same
sex attraction there's nothing to do
with excessive or excess passion now
she's naming celibate Christians here
she doesn't just mean Christian savini
type who have decided to be celibate she
means like um uh saying queer folks you
know same-sex attracted folks uh who and
there is a certain wing of the church
who are kind of they're walking a little
bit of a line where they're saying like
well based on Leviticus Romans 1 other
passages and my interpretation of those
I don't
feel I can
um kind of act out on the same-sex
desires or something
um but to have it I recognize though
that I have a sexual orientation
and that's not a sin you know and so
what the reason she names them here is
because this would be a powerful
testimony for someone coming from a more
traditional standpoint right because
they're this person is saying in essence
like okay I'm like going I guess with
you on certain ways of interpreting this
but I've got to say just to be clear you
know I'm not same-sex attracted because
of excess passion and desire or it's not
I didn't like get bored being straight
and then decide like I need something
fresh and zesty you know like
no this is but here's the thing like we
laugh but in the ancient worlds like
that was
exactly The View
like not just like well that's how some
people like no largely that was the
thought like yeah people have you know
and this is why
um
there's a 4th Century uh writer this is
a Christian writer St John chrysostom
who he illustrates this perspective like
perfectly
um
I mean to an almost comical place he
says this no one can say that it was by
being prevented from legitimate sexual
intercourse that they came to this pass
or that it was from having no means to
fulfill their desire they were driven to
this monstrous insanity
can you see though like no actually
Saint John I love some of your other
writings on this point that is precisely
what we're saying right like
no but you can see where he has this
idea of excessive desire like that like
in other words he has no conception of
sexual orientation
that is not on the radar at all
um he continues when it's contrary to
Nature has something irritating and
displeasing in it so they could not even
claim to be getting pleasure out of it
uh I don't really know what to do with
that
um I just I just it's clear right can
you see where
um Saint John like he's coming from a
perspective that's like as modern folks
again this is even traditionalists on
this point
largely would push back on Saint John
right and would say like yeah no
um that's not why people are gay or
lesbian or no no my friend you need to
be quiet you know stop God is bad you
know like it's embarrassing like it's
just doesn't resonate
um and here's the thing you can hear
even echoes
of this View
um even in Romans 1. because even if you
were to say like well but I feel like
Romans 1 or something was like I mean
not that I'm getting this pushback from
many of you but just outside in the
church when I've had this conversation
one bajillion times with people
um it's often like well but I don't know
if ball has those other things those
exploitative ways of relating if he has
those in mind but okay but still he
certainly has the excessive
less kind of idea in mind you can hear
the Echoes of it um verse 26 of Romans 1
shameful lusts inflamed with lust
shameful Acts that's a lot of Shame and
less language or two verses
um why why is that because that's the
mindset there is no understanding of
sexual orientation in the ancient world
that becomes a very big deal
as we try to Bridge and translate it to
modern day the way um Matthew Vines the
famous Christian writer on these topics
he wrote God in the gay Christian and
um he the way he put it was people often
push back on him and others you know
kind of saying like well you can't you
just can't go against 2 000 years of
Christian tradition on sexual
orientation he's like that is precisely
my point there is no tradition on sexual
orientation and so like the last 30
years
and then we're kind of scrambling to
like try to
be Patchwork together some sort of
theology does that does am I kind of
losing you or is this do you see the
connection
where it's like again what maybe the
quickest way to sum it up would be like
what the biblical writers are responding
to an extremely concerned about are all
sorts of things that either a under the
exploitative banner we would agree like
yeah I have my concerns about all of
that too or be excessive lust kind of
this excessive desire that we would just
be like
that's no I that's like a swing and Miss
like it's just not the way we think
about it even I mean it would be all but
the most kind of ultra conservative
circles like that's just not the
cultural conversation that's happening
um so third she finally Keen says this
some traditionalists also agree that
objection to male male relations on the
grounds of violating gender Norms is
rooted in outdated views of women as
inferior
um to kind of summarize this what she's
getting at is in Israel and in much of
the surrounding cultures um they can
hear Old Testament but also knew like
the Hittites and all the ites in the
Bible the Canaanites
um and Babylonians and Assyrians and
others
um there is basically the view was
um to be a man I'm sorry this will be
outrageously sexist but I'm just giving
you the view I'm not saying this is my
view
um to be a man to be male
um is awesome
uh
it's awesome it's still it is why
because well I mean gosh it's clear you
know
um they would say they would say
um men are you know so intelligent so
strong so um you know active and out
there in the world you know but but a
woman you know woman uh to be a woman is
in their minds it was like
extremely second-class citizen might be
putting it
charitably it would be you know fourth
class citizens like
um and you can see this even the works
like Aristotle and others you know where
it's sort of like
there's a whole hierarchy like male
female slave you know it gives us like
it's messed up not good
um so how did this play out in the realm
of
um same-sex relations well this is a big
thing to them was who and again this is
where sorry I'm trying not to get overly
graphic but in their minds who is the
active partner or the passive partner in
the sexual act was like a huge deal to
them this is why actually like going
back to the Romans culture which to us
is just like cannot relate to this but
in their culture to be the master right
in that Master Slave dynamic they
thought of those men not again not as
like oh are you gay are you this or that
it was those men are very strong and
powerful and manly
because they were the active one but to
be the slave
to be the passive partner to be the
receptive one that was inferior and so
one of their grave fears
is that well same-sexual relations are
wrong in the ancient world because men
are acting like women
does that make sense again I'm not
asking you if you agree or like isn't
that awesome no just
um but if you get it right like that's
can you see where again the Gap is
widening and where it is like a swing
and a miss as far as like yeah like oh
this is something we can all get it's
just like no this is why Keen is naming
even traditionalists
even mini not all but many conservative
Scholars are like
[Applause]
that stuff isn't that's not so good and
it doesn't translate well you can hear
Echoes of it even in Leviticus that
passage we looked at earlier 2013 which
said if a man has sexual relations with
a man as one does with a woman
right can you hear where when that's the
concern it's like
oh my God like they're really freaking
out but for us it's sort of like you
know there's like
who's active and passive and it's like
what no like what what
this just sounds sexist and terrible
like just
yeah
um
so kind of
to just sum up can you can you hear I
hope this has been helpful in the sense
of can you see the gap
can you see how the Gap is widen and why
you know on Facebook when pokes folks
are posting like Leviticus 2013 says
this and I mean can you see where
careful Scholars even traditionalist
conservatives call it read that and know
all that background and so they know oh
you gotta be careful with it oh no no
that is not the place to take your stand
you know they they know and yet for so
long
precisely those passages have been used
to clobber people
clobber like good people
loving people people who just wanted to
love and be loved
who just wanted to like have a
relationship with someone they're
attracted to
like anyone else
like someone who wanted to love and
serve God
and participate in church Community like
anyone else and yet we have
I don't even know how to State it we
have
unbelievably
[Music]
astoundingly misread and misapplied and
misused these texts in terrible ways
and I just I just want to name and I
know I'm totally preaching to the choir
you know but like I just I I say let's
move on
like let's move on from the clobber
passages these texts you know for
Scholars I guess they're you know
interesting but they're just so utterly
irrelevant to the conversation we're
trying to have in even the broader
church needs to have so I think um
some of you many of you may be who like
these texts have just been weighing on
you like just held over your head and
maybe you've been kind of ignoring them
like I'm trying to just you know I'm
just trying to move on my relationship
with God and scripture I'm just trying
to move on but it's like those have been
kind of Haunting you you know
um and maybe not even if you're you know
find yourself as a queer person but
maybe even you know it's for your kids
or for a friend or something you know
I'm just telling you like be free
be free the the folks who understand
like all those Specialists like they
moved on like 15 years ago
um you can too we can too and oh I just
I long for the day
when churches have in fact moved on
and we have we have on so many other
topics I mean I can give you powerful
argument biblical texts on all sorts of
things you'd find very questionable I
mean slavery is a good one you know I
mean just like I could give preach a
powerful sermon on you know but it of
course we'd all know I don't care what
the how you're interpreting that man
that's wrong right
it's it's time to move on so
um let's let's be free and and this is
why the next three weeks as we go
through some more texts and things we
won't be doing the clobber passages we
won't be giving you like more detailed
exegesis of Leviticus 20 or whatever oh
it's just it's it's not um relevant in
the conversation instead I'm kind of
interested
it's like um like what's the Theology of
marriage that makes room for non like
hetero people you know for all people
um I think that's a good question I
think that's some theology I'd like to
that's some bible stuff I'd like to
press into
um or like I mentioned what's Jesus view
on like sexual minorities and things you
know that's those are that that we need
to do right so I'm not saying in church
abandon the conversation never talk
about scripture on these topics again no
I'm just saying like leave these
specific texts
um we don't have to um keep circling
around it
um unless you want to do a deep dive
into the scholarship at which my welcome
sure you want to do that like go for it
it can be powerful and helpful and God
bless you
um but but just know that's not what I'm
gonna be doing in this series so
um all right
let's wrap it up in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit amen
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ and the wine
church we do it as one body
one body
[Music]
one body of Christ One Church
no longer fractured
no longer divided
by
gender
in the
uh
war that can happen across those lines
no longer divided by ethnicity
and the pain in the
um
division that can happen along those
lines no longer divided by sexual
orientation
but one church one body
and uh
so as you come forward to receive the
bread
the body of Christ as you come forward
to receive the wine the blood of Christ
may it be a moment truly of communion of
connection with Christ and in ways
connection with yourself as one loved
scene known by God
um so we practice here what's called an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you want to participate
regardless of denominational affiliation
or your exact theology on XYZ if you
want to connect with the Risen Christ
you just come right down this aisle and
and you you connect also you should know
the red is wine
real one
we're serious Christians and
and the white is um grape juice so um we
encourage especially the kids you know
kids don't sneak the wine okay
um
and uh and then finally the way you can
take it is just partake whenever you'd
like so
um you can come forward receive it then
you can return to your seat and take it
but no one's gonna like lead you through
the exact you know moment and then
finally we'll just kind of start here at
the front and we'll just work our way
um back so this is the table not of the
church
not of the church but of the Lord It's
Made ready for those who love him and
for those who want to love him more so
come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here
come to the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you know after you've like taken in a
lot of information and you're just kind
of like in shock of all that you've just
heard
kind of like drinking from a fire hose
um no it was so good
um
key change
we're gonna sing this song uh together
and this is gonna be the song that we
sing at the end of each service for the
next few weeks it's called for everyone
born a place at the table
um and if you haven't heard this song it
is truly a beautiful beautifully Written
song the lyrics are really special
and we've seen it a few times here and
uh the first time I got to sing it was
at a centerpiece conference and we were
in this room of just like five or six
hundred people uh singing for everyone
born who plays at the table and it was
incredibly special and so we're gonna
sing this together
um so if you'd like to stand please
stand with us
and we're gonna sing this song together
[Music]
[Applause]
um
for everyone boy
a place at the table
and bread
a shelter in space
safe place
[Music]
and create
compassion and peace
peace he is
of Justice
Justice
[Music]
[Applause]
a place at the table
revising the rules deciding
the share
with wisdom and Grace
dividing the powers
[Music]
of Justice
compassion
and peace
are creator creators of Justice
Justice enjoy
[Music]
ing for stray
place at the table
[Music]
oven and shared a welcoming space
a rainbow of rays
gender in colors for gay and frustrate a
chalice of Grace God will the last
we are creators of justice and
Joy
compassion and peace
of Justice
Justice and joy Justice
[Music]
and joy
Justice
[Music]
thank you
all right thank you Ben thank you
everybody for joining us tonight
um this is my first time doing the
closeout and the intro so apologies I
got to read off my notes
but if you are new here we would love
for you to fill out a card we have a
table right out in the front uh just put
down your information and somebody will
follow up with you we'd love to get to
know you and have you join the fam
that'd be awesome if you're in need of
prayer a hug or just general support
myself and Brett and other table members
are here for you if you need to speak
with us find one of us after the service
we'd be happy to be there for you
here at the table we're committed to
creating an inclusive christ-centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is a key component of that
mission if you want to join us in that
we invite you to go to thetabletx.org to
support this work financially
all right I think that is everything
that I'm supposed to say
it was really good to see everybody
who's a very crowded house tonight which
is awesome everybody online thanks for
being there too but I'm going to send
you out with our benediction and a
blessing so if you'd like you can hold
out your hands as a sign of reception
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
[Music]
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
be blessed have a good week and we hope
to see you back here next Sunday good
night
[Applause]
our creator creators of justice and joy
compassion and peace
of justice justice
just as enjoy
[Music]
Justice